A SERVICE ANIMAL UPDATE FOR THE
AGES AND DETAILS THE LATEST BACK
MARK FOR CELEBRITIES.
BUT FIRST, A LITTLE OVER 12
HOURS UNTIL FOLKS START
ORGANIZING THE NEVADA CAUCUSES,
IT LOOKS LIKE DEMOCRATS COULD BE
FACING A REPEAT OF THE FIASCO WE
SAW IN IOWA TWO WEEKS BACK, IF
YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
EXPERTS ARE WARNING OF POTENTIAL
TECHNICAL SNAFUS.
NOW, THE DNC ALREADY VOIDED
1,000 EARLY VOTES.
PARTY CHAIR TOM PEREZ TOLD THE
AP HE WON’T COMMIT TO SAME-DAY
ELECTION RESULTS.
ARE WE A THIRD WORLD COUNTRY?
WE CAN’T ANNOUNCE THE ELECTION
RESULTS THE NIGHT OF THE EL
ELECTION?
DO WE HAVE COMPUTERS ANYMORE?
I GUESS NOT.
I’M COUNTING.
BUT THE COUNTING CHAOS IS
BESIDES THE POINT NOW.
THE REAL QUESTION OF THE NEVADA
CAUCUSES IS THIS -- DO THEY
MATTER?
BERNIE ASSURED A WIN TOMORROW.
AFTER THAT, THE ORDER OF
FINISHES DON’T MAKE THAT MUCH OF
A DIFFERENCE.
AND I FEEL CONFIDENT DECLARING
TONIGHT THAT THIS RACE IS
SHAPING UP TO BE A TWO-MAN SHOW.
SANDERS VERSUS BLOOMBERG,
DESPITE THE HORRIFIC DEBATE
PERFORMANCE WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
THE SAYING GOES, FOLLOW THE
MONEY, "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
IS REPORTING THAT PETE BUTTIGEIG
AND JOE BIDEN HAVE NOT INVESTED
IN ANY ADS IN THE CRUCIAL
SUPERTUESDAY STATES.
AMY KLOBUCHAR AND WARREN
COMBINED PUT LESS THAN $2
MILLION.
AND IN OTHER WORDS, RUNNING OUT
OF CASH, MONEY, AND TIME, BERNIE
IN THE CRASS ROOTS ARMY THROUGH
THEIR OWN PERSONAL FINANCES HAVE
MONEY IN SPADES.
ON TOP OF FUNDRAISING, THOUGH,
BIGGEST TELL FOR WHO THE
FRONT-RUNNER SEES AS HIS REAL
THREAT IS WHOM THEY ATTACK.
BERNIE WILL USE THE SUNDAY 60
MINUTES INTERVIEW TO TAKE DIRECT
AIM AT ONE PERSON AND ONE PERSON
ONLY -- MIKE BLOOMBERG
>> I THINK IT’S QUITE
LIKELY THAT TRUMP WILL CHEW HIM
UP AND SPIT HIM OUT.
>> IF YOU’RE WORRIED ABOUT HIM
BEFORE, ARE YOU LESS WORRIED NOW
ABOUT HAVING THAT DEBATE?
>> I’M WORRIED ABOUT AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF MONEY
BEING SPENT ON A CAMPAIGN.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE’VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY
>> FOR BLOOMBERG, WELL, THE
FEELING OF ANTIPATHY IS MUTUAL.
>> I WORRY WE MAY WELL BE ON THE
WAY TO NOMINATING SOMEBODY WHO
CANNOT WIN IN NOVEMBER.
AND IF WE CHOOSE A CANDIDATE WHO
APPEALS TO A SMALL BASE LIKE
SENATOR SANDERS, IT WILL BE A
FATAL ERROR.
>> AFTER NEVADA, THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY BASE MOVES TO SOUTH
CAROLINA.
NOW, THAT STATE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE JOE BIDEN’S FIRE WALL.
BUT IF BIDEN’S LEAD SHRINKS IN
THE PALMETTO STATE, BLOOMBERG IS
TELLING HIS RICH FRIENDS TO STOP
GIVING MONEY TO BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN
AND SLOWLY LET THE PATIENT BLEED
OUT.